hey everyone thank you for joining
um
uh originally my colleague was meant to
present this but she cannot make it
today I'll be I'll be pretending at her
stead
um
um so that's a QR code for
um the link to the repo and also there's
a custom Jupiter Hub instance where
we'll have like the data that we'll be
looking at and some notebooks but
um feel free to
um
uh go directly so if this is visible
this is the repo uh my GitHub username
and python serving but
you can also directly go to the Jupiter
Hub instance which might be sure it's
just hub2.mp.training
and uh it contains the repo and
um yeah also the in inside the repo you
can find the slides if you're going over
under assets and slides so if you want
to revisit them during the session or
app
so let me get started
um
so the
agenda for so I hope everyone got this
um but yes um so agenda for today I
wanted to kind of briefly talk about
machine learning and Walmart search
uh review some deep learning Concepts
just make sure we're all kind of on the
same page uh talk about how do you take
a model that was trained and how do you
optimize it for production and
um deploy the model with DOT surf from
Facebook and yeah briefly talk about
some lessons learned
um after each kind of section there is
kind of like a Hands-On
um so you know please feel free to ask
you know questions in between or during
those sessions
um yeah so I'm a machine learning at
engineer at Walmart search and my
colleague Ravi is also here today
um
yeah so how in a search system where can
machine learning be used you know
um it's not just something like a user
enters a query you know there are things
like spell check uh correcting like
mistakes that a user might have made
like type ahead recommending
um
recommending things to that a user
wouldn't have to type the full context
related searches uh creating item
embeddings creating query embeddings um
parsing the query intent so there can be
many
layers where machine learning is used
that's for today's session let's mainly
focus on the query understanding so
let's see if you have a query like Nike
men's shoes you know a good query
understanding system should probably
understand that
but there's a brand intent of Nike
there's a gender intent of men there's a
product type intent of like kind of
athletic shoes versus like maybe casual
dress shoes
and uh let's assume like in the catalog
um all these attributes are parsed kind
of properly
so once you understand the query intent
of Nike men's shoes can you match it to
the item at the item side so there can
be several models just involved in this
piece but today let's just focus on
you know given a query can I parse the
product type correctly
so briefly like what is what was the
production infrastructure at Walmart so
um you know last year we had several
production models written in tensorflow
and since we read like a Java shop we
had them you we were serving these
models as services using the Java native
interface uh just like everyone
um every like we saw the benefit of
large Transformer models like bird so we
kind of wanted to start seeing how we
can use that to enrich like the
different layers in a search stack
we wanted to build something that
supported pytouch and kind of Onyx it's
a general uh as a general um Lang as a
general framework for supporting any
future models and since this is serving
the mod model in production we wanted an
SLA of less than like the peak SLA of 40
milliseconds but ideally under like 15
would be really great
um yeah so let me briefly introduce the
data that we'll be looking at today
um
so uh UC Berkeley and Amazon has this
nice kind of e-commerce data where it
has like product data catalog images 3D
models pretty rich data but for today's
session
um since we are only going to build like
a product type classifier we're going to
just look at the product metadata
so if you look at the product metadata
we have things like brand item id item
name and product type so what our model
is going to do it's like given the item
name here's an item title given like an
item title or given a query can we
extract the appropriate product type for
it
um and in the end we'll deploy this
model on dot serve
um it has a post endpoint where we can
basically just given give it the query
and we'll get the top predictions
um this this Workshop you won't really
deal with training because training can
take a long time so I've already trained
the model and made it available inside
that jupyter Hub environment
um so we'll mainly look at you know uh
trying to see like the reviewing how to
do inference with this model review the
inference time for this model
look into some techniques for optimizing
the model packaging it with torch serve
so
um that's basically the high level
overview again if you want to follow
along uh there's the Jupiter Hub
instance uh the bitly link just takes
you to the git repo
yeah and inside the git repo there are
the slides also that we are being com
that are being covered so yeah let me
get started with the first um oh yeah uh
let me let me just briefly show some
notebooks
um we have here
so inside this environment
um
so we're not going to deal with like the
processing or training here but
um Amazon and UC Berkeley made this
really nice data set available so this
is this kind of what the data frame
looks like
um but since in our case since we're
dealing with like item title
um
and that's really the main attribute
that we'll be dealing with and we have
about 147k uh Records so it's a pretty
decent data set
um and
just to maybe not deal with like pandas
we just create like a hugging face data
set with these fields here
and then just did a trained test split
so yeah um so the model's already
trained um let's just maybe go directly
to kind of Hop
you know how would you build a
classifier for this model
let me go
so you know before but before
Transformer models if you want to build
like a simple text classification model
um you might do something where you know
you might tokenize the input you might
feed it to a word embedding layer you
might feed it into your you know lstm or
RNN layer maybe you might have several
several of those layers stacked and then
you might have like a classification
either like a sigmoid or a soft match
depending on whether it can be
product type could be whether you can a
single item can have multiple product
types
um yeah this is a you know pretty this
was a model similar to this is what we
had in production for a very long time
you can you know you can fine tune your
word embeddings with your own you know
Corpus so you don't just need to use the
general word to back
and you know if you add like
bi-directionality you can kind of get
pretty good accuracy for this
there's some Cons with this model
and I think
you know Bert as a Transformer model can
have solve these things you know one
thing is like tokenite tokenization is
always a problem with something like
vertifex which is just a simple
a word word organization algorithm like
if there's like any any new tokens that
are coming in the user's query
um if you use exact match you might miss
them so something like a sub word
tokenizer might be able to solve some of
those issues
um contextualized embeddings like
depending on how long the query is you
might have some scenarios where
um a simple word to vac approach might
not be capturing the right context
you'll see an example of this from our
trained model
um you know vertovac is a pretty
scalable approach for training
embeddings but it it's not like you're
not really training the beddings on your
Downstream task properly so but kind of
with its pre-training kind of uh that's
a bit but sorry that's a better way of
training that problem
and bird in general is a general
language model so it can learn much
better contextualize word
representations than word to back
so
um
the other thing is you know when we talk
about birth like there are many
different variants about like different
sizes of bird uh bird base has 12 layers
you know but there are other smaller
variants of bird that have uh different
numbers of encoders and
as you can see by
the like the Stanford sentiment data set
accuracy depending on the number of
encoders and the architecture you can go
all the way from 83 accuracy to close to
90 accuracy
um obviously the larger the model it is
the higher the inference time will be
so this is an example of the model that
this is an example of the results for
the model that we had before and the
model the bird model that we built in
our company so for a query like betting
for twin extra large mattress
kind of the biostea model uh the top
prediction is mattress
probably because like the top mattress
is the last token but the actual intent
of this query is kind of like the
bedding so with the bird model that was
trained
um bed sheets is the top extracted
product type
so in general like on our holdout
validation data set the F1 score
improved from 0.75 to 0.91
so this is definitely a great model and
we definitely wanted to push it to
production especially looking at the
metrics
um so yeah so let's uh maybe look at
um like if you're new to like the
hugging phase data set apis let's kind
of see how to use them
um use the pre-trained model to kind of
do inference
or fine tune model in this case rather
so
let me
go to this notebook so I'll be going
over
um the training is a bit difficult to do
in the settings we'll just be looking at
this inference review notebook
uh let me just duplicate in case you
know feel free to follow along or read
the rendered run which is
I hope this is big enough to see
um
so
um you know hugging face has done a lot
for the open source ecosystem so we're
importing the Transformers library from
there uh and since this is a pytouch
model the importing touch and some other
dependencies on it I'm already
fine-tuned this model on this data set
so I'm just going to load the checkpoint
using the Transformers
helper libraries helper classes
so here is a distilled bird
model
um
so for I'm given a text it's a 768
dimension
embedding and
we have like 30 product types from this
data set so things like accessory
handbag
um
yep so just
so let's see for some queries here like
um how do you do inference so we have a
query here we have our tokenizer we tell
it to
there's only like five valid tokens but
we uh tell it to pad it to the maximum
length
um and then we have like an attention
mask for like where the tokens were
actually used
and then once we get this
thing one pair of input IDs and
attention mask we feed it into the model
that we saw before
and we get uh
we we get the model outputs and you know
uh in this case the model was trained as
a soft Max so we just
apply softmax and get the top
end results here
so here's the probability here's items
and let's just map it to your labels
that we saw before
what was the query here a cheap
professional men's shoes right so
and the top classes class is 99 on
it so
yeah I am the bird model is very large
to visualize but this is a distilled
bird-based model so there should be like
six encoder layers
um but yeah it's maybe a little bit
difficult to see so I'll just skip this
for now
um
yeah and
I just have some help of code to see
like the accuracy and results but let me
just go for the rendered output
so
um on this data set
this model is getting about
0.95 or 95 accuracy
um yeah so
the one thing to take a look at you know
how long does
um
it take to run inference so this model
on a CPU
um takes about 124 milliseconds
on a GPU it takes about 25 milliseconds
so this is just something to keep in
mind when it's living in production
and let's look at the second notebook
where we compare the timing oh sorry
before I go to this next notebook are
there any questions about the materials
so far
yes
um
um so and I know this is more of an
engineering based talk but for the
is there a way to kind of summarize the
bird like the
the way the bird model works here in
terms of are you kind of just taking
some intermediate embedding from bird
and then training the soft Max on top of
that and just basically doing a
multi-class classification uh
yeah I mean so
uh with the hugging face
um
sorry I didn't go over the training code
here but like um in this case I just
used the hugging face Transformers
Library so
um so it does you know just this helper
Class Auto model for SQL sequence
classification it just takes but takes
the embedding and then it adds I think
by default like one
uh one additional layer and then change
it as the classification piece um
uh you can use like regular pie torch or
by torch lightning to add multiple uh
fully connected layers so more complex
heads that's needed cool thanks
so um go to this other notebook just to
kind of
kind of give an intuition for how long
some of these models take just again
duplicate this
in case and you know please feel free to
follow along or just look under rendered
output
so let me um
foreign
so
[Music]
there's the bird large model
it looks like I didn't download the
checkpoint um yeah so the there's the
bird large model we're going to look at
the bird-based model so bird base has
six encoder heads and then we're going
to look at the distilled Bird model
we'll look we'll cover a distillation
later in the presentation and we also
saw in the previous notebook the timing
for distilled word so
um
yes for the same query let's just see
it's running the inference time now
definitely these models uh it will be
challenging to run in
um in a in a CPU environment in
production so let's see if you can see
some of these results coming up here um
let me also just bring the
let's see okay
take a little bit of time so let's just
look at the rendered output here so when
I did this run
um
uh a while back so for the distilled I
mean sorry for the bird large model
for a single query it takes 734
milliseconds
yeah that's close to a second that's
pretty large especially for an online
use case uh on a GPU uh it's about like
278 milliseconds so
not that much improvement relatively
speaking
um
so bird base so which is half then
encoders so it's 217 milliseconds
on a GPU we're getting about 43
milliseconds so that's maybe on the
higher end like that we have in our
production use case but this is possibly
a candidate uh the distilled Bird model
um okay we on a CPU we're getting 112
milliseconds
and on a GPU they're getting about 26
milliseconds so this is kind of Ideal in
a in in our production use case but I
hope you can see like depending on the
model uh the number of encoded layers
you can go all the way from like 26
milliseconds to
um
uh 278 milliseconds and this is assuming
like
um
obviously there's a much larger expense
cost when you're serving on a CPU which
is a GPU
so that's also something to keep in mind
not just the time
um yeah so I think this this for the two
notebooks I wanted to go over for the
first part
um are there any questions before I
switch or
yes is
so because the other day there's another
speaker mentioned that if you run it
locally you found this a great
Improvement but then you run it on
distributed environment then you find
out it actually not changing that much
yeah so um these timing informations are
like running on gcp like on a N1 Hyman
16 so like the 16 core machine
um and the
uh the GPU is a D4 instance
um I think like
in the cloud environment you're kind of
limited to what Nvidia kind of allows
for the gpus
um but I think like the T4 is a pretty
decent GPU for like runtime inference
um but all these all these numbers are
uh like for a kind of like a small batch
size of one like uh definitely like in a
batch inference use case you can get
much better through put and much better
use
runtime of the GPU so those numbers when
you average it might give a better
picture
that answered that question
um
cool um let me go to the next section if
they're not any other questions
um
so
sorry
so I hope you saw like depending on the
bird model you use it can definitely
take some
effort can definitely affect your
latency and time to serve for the users
and definitely in an online setting this
can be very important
so what are some techniques that we can
use to
improve that latency if any
definitely we saw distillation
drastically reduce the model inference
time so let's briefly cover that also
but let's first talk about the first
technique which is pretty common
commonly used called quantization
so when we train our model like we
trained it on 32-bit Precision floats
um do we really need such a high level
precision
especially for all the layers
maybe some for some of the layers we
could probably convey the same amount of
information with like
uh 16 bits or if it ends
eight bit ins
so if we have if we were able to reduce
the demand the level of precision we
could reduce the memory and also like
um accelerators like gpus still are
faster for in-based computations
definitely a CPU as CPU is much faster
for input based operations
so in the image here we have like a
histogram where uh you have like the
full float distribution but if you could
maybe map it to the scope of an INT you
definitely see like in the bottom uh
chart like we have a loss of information
and precision but it kind of Might
capture the shape of your data enough
especially for some of the layers it
might be sufficient so if you can find
that matching
it might work for your model
and the whole idea here is that
because int-based computations is faster
um if you can have some layers of your
model using this not only do you reduce
the memory consumption needed you can
also increase the computation speed
and pytote supports three different
types of quantization
first one is you quantize the weights of
your network so you have your model
saved your quantize the weights you save
it then during run time
as the input goes through the model
um when you do a multiplication with the
weights you quantize the activations and
then you do the multiplication with the
weights and then you feed it over to the
next layer so
um
you you keep doing this operation of
like mapping the activations uh to ins
and then
multiplying it with the weights but
um
yeah so you keep having this operation
of mapping from floats to ins but
depending on the layers that you do it
it might not be a big drop in accuracy
one benefit of using this approach is
you know you don't need you can do it on
your model that's already trained you
don't need to do any operation for you
know like having a calibration data or
whatnot so this is a very easy operation
to do
um and you can also choose to do it only
for some layers
the two other techniques that I also and
pipe here's an example in pytouch which
is called
torch.quantization.quantize Dynamic and
then in this thing here you see we are
passing just the linear layers of the
model and we are I'll be telling it for
that specific layer we want to use
interface quantization
the other two techniques are kind of
similar one is static-based quantization
here you're quantizing both the weights
and activation
but in order to do that you need some
calibration data so while the model
um in the previous step like we had
these activations that
was being quantized on the slide but
here
um because we're giving some calibration
data it will find like a much better
mapping
um yeah and because there's no like
converting back the floors to ins back
to floats
um a performance on this model should be
faster
there's a slight variant to this called
uh like static quantization or
quantization of air training the idea is
like if you're going to quantize your
model
um why not
consider your quantization error as part
of all your models being trained
um so not only will your model be
trained to reduce the accuracy I mean
like improve the accuracy or training
loss you can tell your model I want you
to also optimize the quantization error
loss
um this leads to the best results
how the results look in practice
so
um so three different type of models so
you know bird resnet and mobile net for
image classification
uh the First Column the 32-bit accuracy
um for bird let's just focus on that so
we have about 90 percent
if you change it to
um int based accuracy for like the
linear layers
um
you you get about you know 89 so that's
still good but if you look at the uh
inference performance we have about
close to 2x speed up I think that's
really great for like such a very
minimal drop in accuracy
but if you look at
um other things like for like rest net
um
uh what
what do you see yes so um
for some of these convolution models you
can't really do like this uh Dynamic
quantization
um you need to do like static
quantization or conversation of their
training so with those techniques you
get also like a 2X and in the case of
mobile net you're getting like a uh
close to a 6X performance going all the
way from close to 100 milliseconds to 17
milliseconds uh the mobile net numbers
is like on numbers on like on a phone so
on like more Edge devices you might see
the benefit of quantization more
um yeah so the other technique
um that you can use to optimize your
um
model inference time is distillation the
idea is like maybe when you train your
model you might have a large teacher
model
or you might have a large model that
kind of tries to explore the whole space
but
um once the once this large model has
explored the space you might try to
distill that information to maybe a
smaller model
so large models like Bert especially
with a large number of encoders it has a
large learning capacity
but maybe like a biolistium
um it just cannot capture maybe all that
information in your information space
so let's look at the results of this
model in practice
so
um so let's consider a bird large model
so on the Stanford sentiment data set it
has about like a 95 accuracy
and you have a student Model A bile STM
model so the biostia model by itself has
about like 86 accuracy
but if you distill that model with
information that was learned from bird
Lodge you get about a 90 accuracy
so a biosteam model is very cheap to
kind of serve and run and by the fact
that you were able to increase it like
by four percent by just distillation is
it's a great Improvement
yeah so those were like the
two main things like uh quantization
distillation
the other thing is like a small thing to
just keep in mind is like one of the
reasons why Pi torch became very popular
is uh the fact that by default it was an
eager execution mode
when while tensorflow kind of made it a
little bit difficult and it was always
in graph mode it was a little bit hard
to debug but there's a cost for kind of
this ease of use
on this ego execution mode is not ideal
for production
um although you allow it allows you to
get immediate feedback so in order to
make it ideal for production you you
need to convert it to script mode
um and one of the things that happens in
script mode is you're creating an
optimized execution graph and
um when you convert your model to script
mode you can also just serve it in a
pure C plus runtime you kind of decouple
the Python
the python binding is a use case for
that and technically it's also
representing the model in like
touchscript which is like a
pytotus intermediate representation of
this model
yeah
so this is just something to keep in
mind is that this is a step that you
might need to take um
but luckily pytouch makes it easy to go
to script mode
um yeah just some small details like
maybe in the future this might be fixed
but right now there's like two different
types of ways to convert it to script
mode but the basic idea is like you're
passing it some input data and torch
script looks at how the model gets
activated and tries to create like an
optimized execution graph
um one layer one type tracing is more
flexible but uh scripting is maybe a
little bit more performant but there
might be some limitations so one
limitation
is
um so if in your operation you're doing
like if else operations like in this
forward step if you're doing a defense
step like changing the weights or
something based on the input this is
something like the script mode might not
be able to support
um
so let's see what is the Improvement
that we get so here we're taking the
same model
um same pytouch model and you're doing
this dot scripting process that we just
talked about
so we're going from 1.3 seconds all the
way to 768 milliseconds
um by just doing that tracing operation
that we talked about
um definitely you see a large
Improvement on this CPU and GPU by raw
numbers it's a little bit smaller but
you're still seeing improvements here
so we explored our three
three techniques uh quantization
um
distillation and this
this execution of tracing so let's kind
of explore these things in a lab
so this is covered in lab let me just
shut down all the
kernels
so this would be in optimizing the model
and um all these models they have some I
mean all these notebooks have
intermediate files but
um the intermediate files are also
included in this environment so if you
want to just follow along with a
specific notebook you should be able to
do that
um
so let me just duplicate this notebook
um yeah maybe before I run this notebook
are there any questions on the slide so
far
let me just run this
so
um we are taking this model that was
trained
um you know I'll find you not on our use
case
it's just um
I just create like a subset so we can
just evaluate the results of the models
so we covered three things right Dynamic
quantization static quantization and
quantization of their training
um
if you want to do like static
quantization you need to give it some
calibration data
so which might be a little bit difficult
so for now I'm just going to use dynamic
quantization
so as we saw like we can choose to give
which layers we want to quantize and the
level of quantization
so like if you look at the regular
distilled word model we see like
um there's several linear layers here
and in the Transformer there's several
linear layers here so what we are seeing
is for this for those type of layers we
want to convert them to eight withins
so after doing that operation we see
like the the layer type has changed
um
and um
we also see that the size the model the
size of the model has changed so it was
before 267 MB and now it's 138
um since not all the model layers are
quantized so that's why you don't really
see like a
4X kind of decreasing going from 30 to
bit to 8-bit
um
yeah so let's see if the quantization
time
let's run so
yeah
so
um for the original model we had 306
milliseconds
just that single Quant single
quantization we reduce a bit here to 246
milliseconds and you know this is
already a distilled Bird model so we're
doing this optimization on top of that
um there's some limitations in pi torch
about like
at least when I ran this notebook a
while back it didn't support like
quantization for some of the Jeep for
for some of the layers for like in a GPU
environment I think this issue is fixed
now but yeah
yeah so a quantized linear layer is only
available for the CPU backend
but I think this issue is fixed now
um so when I did this
um
uh results I computed this results in
the past so
um for this distill bit model
um the accuracy as you see is like not
really there's not really much drop
especially for this data set but we went
from 116 milliseconds on a CPU
uh to 83 milliseconds with quantization
and again this model A distilled Bird
model on a GPU can run inference in 17
milliseconds so
we have already met
our use case at work by distilling and
running on the GPU but we can still see
improvements on the CPU
yeah so
um
dot script
um luckily hugging face makes it a
little bit easy so you can when you load
uh
the wrapper class you can say like dot
script equals true and
there's like some decoupling that needs
to happen inside the model but luckily
torscript or luckily hugging face makes
it easy
um yeah let me see if I have numbers for
that
um
yeah I think this is the let me see if I
have one
yeah I think this is the final thing
where I output it here so
as we mentioned
um for DOT scripting there's scripting
or tracing
but
um at least in this data set and in this
environment
um with our regular 32-bit
um floating Point Precision we save like
six milliseconds
um by just keeping the same level of
precision
but after like quantizing and tracing
you know we we can reduce it all the way
to 90 milliseconds so like all these
small things like can add up a little
bit
um but maybe it's not as much visible in
this data set
um
so let me so I had any questions before
I go to the next section on oh yes so
apart from just running through pytorch
and advertising
sorry uh instead of just quantizing like
different weights and just still using
pie torch yeah why not go to like a more
inference optimized runtime Electronics
yeah that's a great question so
um I didn't I didn't have the notebooks
for Onyx but like at work that that's
the environment that we use um we
started with the pie tortion
um uh yeah the torch script kind of
runtime but then we moved directly to
Onyx I think Onyx especially I think now
I think hugging face has a new library
of tuna or something like where
um it makes this process much simpler
and it also does things like layer
Fusion which we didn't really talk about
here but yeah that's a great Point yes
thank you
yes
what to what extent do these techniques
apply to like the BART model or is it or
is it more hugging face dependent
well I mean the techniques that we
talked about are not
um even specific to pie torch like you
can even do it with tensorflow like they
are
um I mean Bart versus Bert
oh okay oh
um
I don't know the details about bot but
like um like things like quantization we
saw it being used like it
um you know like
um for like cnns even
um so quantization is a
Global technique that can be used
everywhere
um
what I meant was um to what extent does
how hard is it to do if you're not using
hugging faces oh
techniques which you've uh yeah so as
you
um so in a regular pie torch model like
like
a quantization is one of the most
easiest thing to do like you're just
using regular torch and you there's no
hugging face Rapture or anything so
definitely that's easiest to do
um I think like another person mentioned
like I think the Onyx run time
um does a lot more things like feed
operated fusions and all those things so
that also can just be used with a
regular uh torch model you don't need to
use like the the uh hugging face wrapper
or whatnot although they have a new
wrapper that makes it very easy
um
so let's see
um yeah so I'm going to go on the last
section here
where
um
so you know whichever technique you used
or combination of techniques we now have
like a pie torch binary that we want to
serve so how do you how do you want to
go about serving it so
so you know the first option that you
could do especially if you're under
python ecosystem is you know use a
regular web server like flask or fast
API or variants of that
um or you can use one of those
model specific Frameworks like door surf
from Facebook or Nvidia Triton
or if you or if this was a regular
um tensorflow model you could use
tensorflow serving
so
you know what are some benefits of kind
of using Toyota or slash a model serving
option a model server option so one is
um you know like fast fast API they're
very nice and simple to get started with
but there's some different
considerations you need to think about
when you are serving models so
um you might have a scenario where in
the same web server same service you
want to sell multiple models and maybe
one model you want to sell it with CPU
enter the model you want to serve it on
gpus and maybe for the CPU like two CP
models one of them you want to allocate
more workers and one of them you just
want to allocate one worker
um yes so
um something like toteserve or Nvidia
Triton allows or supports multi-model
serving another thing to think about is
like especially in production you might
have a use case where you might have a
model that's serving prod and then you
have a case where you want to test a new
variant of a model so things like model
versioning and handing those requests I
think the model serving Frameworks are
built a little bit to think about that
um the other benefit
is like server side batching
so if you have a scenario where you know
you're getting high
High number of requests
if by default like Fast API a flask you
know it's dealing with a single request
and even if they're served on a GPU
you're always going to be sending a
single request to the GPU
but these model serving Frameworks what
you can do is you can say like hey uh um
if I'm getting a certain number of
requests and they all come within like
two milliseconds or something I want you
to automatically take all those requests
batch them together to the GPU so this
makes better usage of the GPU and can
increase I mean can decrease your
latency
and also
um these model Frameworks kind of
support like notion of like
pre-processing and post-processing input
which is you know it's not just feeding
the input as you saw when we passed the
model we needed to tokenize it then we
needed to parse the mapping so
um Frameworks like this have better
conceptualized that idea compared to
just a regular web server
so how do you use dotserv which is from
Facebook so
uh
there there's the first step you need to
do is create like a mod file which right
now is just basically like a zip file so
torch has a utility called the torch
model archiver
uh you give it like a model name model
version
um you give it a path to Your Pie torch
file
um you tell it where you want to export
it and you tell it what other packages
you want to package as part of your mod
file so that might include like your
tokenizer config
um it might include like any other
config files that you want your model
handled to read when it does inference
and then the final thing is you you need
to give a reference to a pytorch file
that will handle the request once it
comes to your Handler
um this is a bit maybe small but they're
um this is if I'm writing a Handler
completely from scratch
so in a Handler the main method is
called handle so in the handle method
you
um when you have an input there's a
pre-process step an infant step and a
post-process step
um if you're using
if your use case is very similar to what
um some of the handlers that Facebook
has already provided
um you can just you can use the existing
method but if not you can also override
the
um those steps so these
um
these steps like pre-process and post
process it's already a default
implementation provided by the inbuilt
totes of Handler but you can also
override it for your use case
and um these are some of the default
handlers that have that are already
provided for inside python so if you
have an image classifier you just need
to add like maybe two three lines of
code because you can use the existing uh
handlers that are provided by Facebook
um yeah and then you have your mod file
how do you actually serve it so in
toteserve which is the actual web server
you give it a config file that basically
says Which models you want to load which
IP addresses you wanted to listen
and the location of your models and this
is the batch size that we talked about
so we want to ideally create batch sizes
of 20 with a maximum delay of 2
milliseconds
so if you if you're getting like
hundreds of requests and they all come
like per millisecond uh tote server will
automatically bash them with batch sizes
20 feed it to your GPU and de-batch it
and send it to your
um handlers it's all kind of um
yeah it's all kind of abstract in a nice
manner
so you've started your web service uh
torture has two endpoints for three
endpoints at the exposed one is like a
management API you know you can show
Which models are there what versions
they're being served what is the number
of handlers that are being served there
uh and then when you make a post request
to 8080 in this case and the model name
similar to tensorflow serving
with the post request it goes to your
Handler method and Returns what you have
defined in your handle method of either
the post process method
so let's look at the small notebook for
actually serving this piece so this will
be the last notebook
um
foreign
we kind of saw these things in the
slides so in our case
um
since this is like version one of our
model I just called it version one model
name as PT classifier and the location
of the model so this is where
when I call like the
Transformers Library dot save this is
where the model is there
um I also have the traced model if I
want to reserve that
um yeah and this is just the
handler.pi code let me just go here so
this is
so this is if I'm defining everything
from scratch right
um so
um if you're using like existing
handlers you don't need to do it but
like in your case at work or whatnot if
you want to build something standard so
maybe one thing you want to do is like
when your request is coming in you want
to log it in a certain way when a
request is being post-processed you want
to maybe send some metrics to a
different service so you can kind of
build something like a generic Handler
for your use case so onboarding future
models are easy
but in general your request comes to
your handle method you have like the
context
you can send
you can send the data to your
pre-process inference and post process
steps so
um like let's look at in the use case
that we have here like the pre-process
step
I read all the requests
it might be coming in the body
I compute the
um if I tokenize it gets the input IDs
attention mask and then feed it to
and just return this piece here at my
infant step I'm getting this patch
that's provided and I just feed it in a
model
um
and I can do the mapping of the
uh IDs to the labels in the post process
step or in the inference step itself
so you do have some flexibility there
and again this is if you're
if you're implementing the Handler
completely from scratch there are some
built-in handlers where you don't need
to implement all these
so I package the model there's a mod
file right now it's just basically a zip
file so you can actually use like Zip
just unzip it and see it
this is the Handler that we talked about
um
let's see
so I I
create copied the mod file to like my
model store folder which is just empty
you can just put the files there and
then in toteserve this is the command
you can use to run it
um let's see so once towards your start
it has it provides these logs so the
metrics logs and these logs you can
which you can also push to Prometheus or
whatever monitoring system that you have
um again if you look at the logs we see
um the model has started
these are the endpoints by default that
are provided but you can overwrite them
as needed
if I hit this admin endpoint I see that
I have one model loaded
um if I hit that specific and model I
see details like how many workers are
provided by default it will use all the
CPU workers that are available and
on a GPU it'll create one worker per GPU
um yeah so batch size is just one
and this is how you can make a simple
request to the model
herbal tea here in this case it's under
grocery for example what we saw before
um yeah so
and
um one small file slide that I had so
this image is a bit small but
um
we already like
um so this is with all those metrics
that are emitted from
um
from tote syrup you can you know build a
graphana dashboard it's the model that
we talked about the PT classification
model
after like distillation and actually
also certainly not Onyx we are getting
uh like under seven milliseconds so uh
definitely distillation quantization
Onyx
these things can definitely be used to
make serving uh
these large Transformer models are
reasonable in production we are serving
on gpus so that that's also why we're
getting like under 10 milliseconds
um yeah and this is the last slide I had
um
um did anyone have any questions on
notebooks or materials that was covered
so far
oh yes
um have you experimented with faster
Transformer and seen that
um yeah so there was a colleague that
experimented with fast Transformers but
um
I think um there was like some issue
that we had when packaging it with
totesev when we first explored it but
um we we haven't exploded since like six
months ago so yeah I'm not sure so if
you use the faster Transformer out
Kraken has the ability to support fast
Transformer directly natively in it okay
so you don't need to go through
okay yeah um one thing one reason why we
didn't
we weren't necessarily impressed with
like Triton per se is like we wanted to
add some flexibility like for
pre-processing and post-processing step
like in defining it in Python itself um
and when we looked at Triton back then
um it seemed definitely there was a gap
but we haven't explored it since then so
in the last year Titans added something
called a python back end where you can
use your python code to run
pre-processing or the model itself
directly even a post process okay
awesome yeah I didn't know about that
thank you that's something to look at
here
yes we looked at the like cashing some
of the
embedding especially for like very
common
Aquarius
yeah so um one thing we don't I didn't
mention here is like
it's very expensive and maybe not good
like serving every single request um
live from the model so uh and if you
think like in an e-commerce setting
where there's like head traffic and hail
traffic probably for head traffic you
can have a cash I mean these especially
there's no like context yeah like if you
give if you give a query like it's not
like the PT changes so you can
definitely cache it for like days even
so definitely you don't need to hit the
model for every course yeah so that's a
great Point yes
yes
um thank you for the talk this covers a
lot of stuff that I've been working on
early and
um I mean your talk covered as well my
work has been being done for you
um there are a lot of libraries out
there that purport to be uh like kind of
optimized like optimizers for like that
like I know Olive does it now Onyx
runtime I think does distillation and
does quantization for you have you seen
like what
have a couple different questions here
but the first part is are there any
particular standouts in in Auto applying
you know a library that really does a
good job of applying distillation and
quantization in particular and what is
like what's the most promising stuff in
the field in your opinion because we've
got the pytorch auto Optimizer we've got
the olive Optimizer we've got the Onyx
runtime Optimizer so it's it's kind of
hard to navigate all these things when
you're new to the field yeah I think
like
um recently like hugging face
has a new library that makes it easier
to use like the Onyx runtime
I think it's like just two lines like
for dynamic quantization it's just like
two lines of code
um so like some of the ease of use I
think that different like
um
the hugging face Library makes it easy
um I think like quantization is a
technique that's very easy to use
um whether using regular like the pie
torch binding so like some other
wrappers around it
um I think like distillation
especially like that so I'm going back
to Dynamic quantization since you don't
need to provide like any calibration
data or whatnot it's just calling those
apis
but static quantization or quantization
aware training like we tried exploring
quantization aware training but it can
just be a little bit difficult to kind
of get the model architecture correct
um but I think now there are like some
libraries or help us that make it easy
but I think for us like
um we've kind of stuck with like Onyx
which is fine
it kind of abstracts like some of those
fusions and things a little bit easy but
definitely for our case we needed to
server on GPU to kind of meet rsla so
cool are there any other questions
cool yeah I mean uh so the
um here's the repo the slides that were
covered are inside here
um
and the notebooks are here you know feel
free to produce them
and yeah feel free to reach out in the
future and whatnot for any questions or
whatnot
yeah thanks thanks